many in the u.s keep looking back
political debate still rages in the days
after the acquittal of former president
donald trump
for his role in the capital riot he
watched the impeachment proceedings from
his
new home in florida it's a political
battleground that remains divided over
trump
and the country's future donald trump
is a hero to willie guardiola he lives a
30-minute drive away from the former
president's home
in palm beach he's never met trump
but is a staunch supporter who doesn't
believe he lost the election
it's a big lie i still believe in him i
still believe that he is the
leader of this country i still refer to
him as our president
after leaving the white house trump has
been living at mar-a-lago
this private club for the rich is set to
be both his residents
and headquarters he doesn't want to be
just another senior
playing golf the head of the house
republican conference has already paid
him a visit
yet on this playground of millionaires
and billionaires people are wary
despite trump's acquittal at his second
impeachment trial many rich neighbors
and generous benefactors are now keeping
their distance
after the insurrection things changed he
became a dangerous damn
damaging character and many people don't
want any more to do with him
that's why some people are saying
they're leaving the club
but many of more modest means are
diehard trump supporters
some call in daily to a conservative
radio talk show
hosted by brian mudd there people
believe the impeachment trial was simply
a witch hunt dirty jobs
al what say you would you vote for trump
again of course i would
he shook things up in washington d.c
that's one of the reasons why they got
rid of him
there are many conservative media
outlets in florida with hosts like mud
who want to continue supporting trump's
political future
there's a lot of personal sacrifice
there there are very few examples
in modern times i think that are
analogous to what we've seen with donald
trump
and their faith in him hasn't wavered
every friday locals get together at this
intersection
organizer guardiola thinks trump should
simply dissolve the republican party
so come up with a new name a facelift
and bring in people who are going to be
loyal to
america first trump second and you know
put your hand on the holy bible
and these people would love to be part
of that new movement that supposedly
will be launched soon from trump's new
headquarters in florida
dw correspondent stephan simons is in
washington where he asks
if people in the u.s can come together
again after the trump years
the walkways and streets around the u.s
capitol are covered with a thin layer of
ice
things are still frosty in washington
one day after the historical impeachment
trial
and acquittal of former president donald
j trump
the past week of drama and excitement in
the capital right here
is finally behind us the second
impeachment
and acquittal of donald j trump now
former president
donald j trump is also behind
us is it time to move on democrats
managed to get
seven republicans to vote with them to
vote
for a conviction of donald trump for
what happened here
on january 6. but now it's all over
and is it time to move on
and if so how
i think there's a lot of a lot that
needs to be done before we can all heal
from everything that's happened
so it's not over yet i don't think it's
over it's time to move on yes
from the previous administration but
it's still time
to heal and go back to normal because
we're not normal yet
you have to move on but the thing is i
don't think he should have been a piece
this
stuff he's still looming you know
and i'm just still um sick and disgusted
that he got to quit it
you know it's not right it's not right
at all
but moving on from donald trump won't be
easy
what the former president symbolizes and
means politically for people on each
side of the political spectrum
is rather complex if the reasons that
trump became elected are no more
i think the country will move on if they
continue to exist
i don't really see how that happens here
in the white house the biden
administration is
quite delighted that the impeachment
trial of
donald trump is already over why because
this administration needs the senate
needs the republicans
needs a functioning senate to pass laws
to
actually push policies through the
institutions of the united states of
america
and don't forget joe biden promised he
will be the president
who unifies the country who helps the
country to heal
and who brings back republicans
and democrats in a common effort
to do good for this country i have to
hope that they're going to be working
together and that it'll be better
i also don't think donald trump is a
unique thing that came up four years ago
i think this has sort of been building
up for a while
and hopefully the country can move on i
think it would be nice to hear the
country finally
after all this but i just think
president trump is just so vindictive
that he's just not done
he's he's just not done with or without
donald trump in the picture
coming together politically is likely to
remain a challenge for the country
perhaps only time will help